foreign
[Music]
we're here in southern Ukraine where the
military has given us very rare access
to high Mars which are very mobile
artillery devices the Americans have
given the ukrainians 16 of these since
June
is
[Music]
these highmars have been critical to
some of the recent counter offenses the
ukrainians have launched against Russian
positions the systems carry usually six
missiles which at the at the moment have
a range of 80 kilometers allowing the
ukrainians to strike deeper into
russian-held territory than any other
system they've had
The Operators we spoke to this week told
us that these high Mars now make up 70
percent of the Firepower deployed near
the front lines
these soldiers aren't allowed by the
Ukrainian military to be identified by
their names equally is
he's five
the hymers are hitting everything at
this point ammo Depots headquarters
Bridges groupings of personnel tanks
vehicles
um
these weapon systems have changed the
course of the war for Ukraine they've
allowed the military to start pushing
back taking back lands as they have in
the past few weeks both in the southern
front and as well as in donbass and up
in the north
currency
Russia's defense minister has told
Russian troops to make Ukraine's
long-range Weaponry a priority Target in
a sign that Ukraine's additional
Firepower is taking a toll on moscow's
forces
Russia still occupies large swaths of
Southern and Eastern Ukraine and the U.S
had promised to send 18 more High Mars
as part of a multi-year plan but to
fight off Russia's Invasion Kiev is also
asking for other Advanced weapons like
tanks and fighter jets from its Western
allies